en panamá inicio la audiencia preliminar
para saber si es llamado a juicio o no
el ex presidente ricardo martinelli y
otra veintena de personas por un caso
denominado new business una
investigación que inició en 2017 por
presunto blanqueo de capitales que
habría involucrado fondos públicos y la
utilización del sistema financiero
nacional e internacional para la compra
de un medio de comunicación en el año
2010 año en el que gobernaba martinelli
el ex jefe de estado se ausentó de la
audiencia a sus abogados alegando que
por incapacidad médica y además
introdujeron una serie de recursos que
impedirían en este momento según ellos o
involucre en el proceso judicial dentro
de los recursos a los que apela la
defensa se encuentra el tratado de
extradición entre estados unidos y
panamá que data de 1904 y que dejaría
sin efecto cualquier proceso judicial
distinto al que produjo su extradición
recordemos que martinelli en 2018 fue
entregado por la justicia norteamericana
a panamá por el caso de las escuchas
ilegales del cual quedó absuelto
mientras no existe un pronunciamiento
oficial y éste en torno al tratado de
extradición no esté totalmente claro el
nombre del expresidente seguirá siendo
mencionado no sólo en este sino en otros
procesos judiciales previstos para 2022
entre los que se encuentra el caso de
derecha mientras esto sucede martinelli
ya ha hecho pública su intención de
liderar una nueva candidatura
presidencial en panamá para el año 2024